[Music]
two men have gotten in big trouble for
airing their racist beliefs within
earshot of a microphone now last week
Nevada rancher cliven Bundy was all over
the news after expressing his
pro-slavery beliefs to a New York Times
reporter and now of course Donald
Sterling's been banned from the NBA for
life because of his recorded racist
remarks
well unbelievable a company has already
jumped in to provide a new service for
people like Bundy and Sterling here's
their ad take a look are you're secretly
recorded racist comments ruining your
life why not get away from it all with a
vacation on racist Caribbean cruise line
our cruise ships float exclusively in
international waters miles away from the
closest news journalist or vengeful
ex-girlfriend so you can chill out MOG
and let the prejudice flow all while
enjoying world-class mildly seasoned
cuisine from celebrity chef Paula Deen
buy the white keys white Sabbath the
white eye peas please
white Mambazo Ted Nugent
like it is comedian richie blanco and
they say white men can't jump no no no
white men don't have to jump okay but we
pay them for this guy knows what I'm
talking about
[Applause]
relaxing ranting and letting you racist
flag fly
all while preserving your anonymity in
one of our exclusive privacy hoods being
cruise lines where it's never felt so
right to be white
[Applause]